let's go C 5 C 5 C 5 mm okay
East six retains some flexibility I
don't know what I want to do with my
kingside pieces just yet east 6d six big
difference
maybe this Bishop now has the
possibility of coming here if d6 was in
there that's not happening is it Queen
c7 still retaining some flexibility I
want to learn a little bit more about
what these bishops want to do or maybe
see if White's gonna run first with that
four okay maybe I will still delay my
king side development and get this in
before Bishop to f3 is played and then
maybe this could be a bit of an
inconvenience so there should be seven
just the just following through here b5
Bishop b7 they go hand-in-hand
now what I've made a lot of pawn moves I
only have my Queen out this is a prevent
this Knight does not want to get kicked
away and now I think this is the correct
move to be going with next to force
white into doing some defensive on e4 f3
is played I think I have been successful
because one of the things that white
would like to do is get in this f4 move
but now it's uh
has defensive duties so do I play d6 or
do I play Bishop c5 and then pawn push
or do I consider Bishop d6 I think I
might want to do that I'm actually going
to do that Bishop d6 there is no sac on
this square I could get out of a an
eventual fort by giving check here
so I'm gonna do this first Bishop here I
don't believe I'm missing anything if
this if this King was not castled I've
said this in a previous stream if he
wasn't castled Bishop d6 is a blunder
just because of you actually have as
white he'd have a couple options but
Knight takes pawn here Knight on D takes
pawn is leading to a big world of hurt
this Bishop Falls this Bishop Falls the
bishop pears gone it's a big problem or
actually no you know what there's a way
out of it because of a you know I'm
mistaken I'm if the king was on e one so
there wouldn't be a check on this
diagonal now there is maybe my queen can
end up here white would be without the H
and G pawns and then I don't know what
the follow up is if I really wanted to
go for a draw or something I could just
going back and forth my queen at the end
of it but I'm not gonna do that instead
I'm going to get on a better diagonal
I've weakened to the light squares by
first taking a pit stop on d6 and maybe
I could look into h5h for a bit later
but I think I want some more development
in d6 seems like the right thing to do I
want to develop my night on d7 that way
it's not in the way of my light square
bishop so that's why d6 watch over 'if
I've vacate d7 a couple moves away from
being fully developed so now what
okay
that's just to protect the bishop if I
push that night away and move earlier
the knight would play to f5 and be
defending the bishop and I don't know if
I would have a a good continuation I
didn't even look at it but I'm pretty
sure I wouldn't have a good continuation
I would really just turn out to be
weakening my d5 square so I take the
bishop or just back up what would you do
you think about the answer before I
share my own thoughts I think that could
help improve your game
subject your own thoughts what would you
do take backup I'm backing up because
this cannot be comfortable having the
Queen on c1 light would love to finally
just have the Queen out and have the
rooks connected if anything that let
this happen and I I maintain control
over this square now my last question is
do I run with castle all right try for
something like h5 h4 I think that it's
best just castle and I'm foreseeing that
I will be able to get the d5 move in
successfully and the position will be
opening up the D file will be opening up
and my rooks once on the D file will be
eyeing that second rank squared D - once
there it could definitely end up causing
white some serious problems especially
since this F pawn has moved the Jeep on
has moved the the second rank is a bit
weak so let me do this first looking to
open up the position my queen is in a
good spot kind of boxing this night out
oftentimes you'll see a bishops
placement opposite the knight two
squares if they're both on the same file
two squares separating will often just
be negating that piece so I don't want
to capture with the pawn I want my
bishop to be able to see the
Lord clearly I want to have direct sight
of f3 and as a follow-up move I could be
running with my other Knight to f6 which
rook should play to d8 not sure and I
don't know that it really matters I
think I would be going with this one
these are this is an open file and a
half open and that's just a blender
right that's just a blender okay they
were I think they were ready to just
resign before I captured they said oops
this happens don't feel bad about it at
all
it happens let's flip the board white
side open Sicilian what can you do
better I wonder if there's something
else you could be running with you might
want to consider well I mean you have
the possibility since I'm not putting
immediate pressure on this pond you have
the possibility for maybe getting in c4
Knight c3 c4 will do two things make d5
a bit more difficult to get in and also
the b5 move so you could consider this
you can also consider developing your
LightSquared Bishop to d3 and castling
and maybe bringing this Knight over here
in this direction I think after maybe
even an f4 idea I think I as black I am
successful at this point by putting
pressure on this pawn in a very timely
way and you having to play your pawn up
to defend this and not be able to play F
for yourself and threaten then e v to be
kicking away my King Knights position I
think this is an issue so I think you
really need to try to get an F for
Bishop f3 maybe if you could have that
way or that that sort of setup coming up
I'm not a hundred percent sure I'm just
throwing out some some different ideas
but I don't think black really has too
many problems unless white is able to
get this Pandu Oh on e4 and f4 so you
should be looking to somehow get that in
d5 is often the equalizing move
I was just probing for weaknesses with
the Bishop d6 move and soon enough once
d5 came here I think black is at least
equal and will certainly have the safer
King